[Music]
Hey it's me, Destin.
The idea, here at Smarter Every
Day, is to make you smarter.
I guess it was 1872, the
governor of California
tried to solve the age old question:
When a horse runs, are
all four of its hooves
off the ground at any point in transit?
Now, artists of the day
liked to show images with
the horses' feet up front
and in back off the ground.
So he commissioned a guy
named Eadweard Muybridge
to create a series of images
while the horse was running.
Now, Muybridge was pretty sharp, so what
he did is he strung some strings out,
and had a man ride the horse
through the series of strings
and each string was
associated with a camera.
Basically, it was a time of arrival switch.
So, this was pretty interesting.
Now this is a pulse
generator,
given to me by acompany in Montana
called Quantum Composers.
It is amazing. It is a time machine
without the flux capacitor, basically.
Time for science.
What we're gonna do, is we've
got a piezoelectric transducer
rigged up to this thing
on the trigger input.
All you have to do is just trigger the
thing acoustically and it flashes.
And this is programmable down to
the 25 picosecond resolution.
Here's a 1.8 second flash after...
[snaps fingers] the sound.
So, it's pretty awesome. Anyway...
So what we're gonna do is to create a
series of high speed photography images
and put them together in a video, just
like Muybridge did, back in the day.
So, let's do it.
Weapons are not toys.
What you're about to see was
done by educated, experienced
personnel in a controlled environment.
Be smart.
Let's load.
Muybridge bullet, take one. Here we go.
[Gunshot]
[Pulse generator beeping]
This is what the video looks
like straight up, just as shot.
And this is what the video looks like once
I correct for the ballistic variance,
And go in there and, uh... put
them in order, in distance.
So, pretty cool.
Okay, so some of you are thinking,
"that's awesome! No clue what it means."
So let me explain.
Commercial high speed
cameras are very expensive,
But what we've done, for repetitive events,
we've created one at a
fraction of the cost,
and at 7 times the resolution of 1080p.
So like Muybridge, we've
combined simpler technologies
to create something that was
technologically out of our reach.
It's pretty cool.
I've got some improvements
to this, keep an eye on me.
Alright, it is way too late to be
playing with guns and time machines,
so I gotta go to bed.
Um, today we did art, science, math...
a little bit of history,
we played with guns and cameras.
That's pretty awesome. So if you would,
subscribe and tell all your friends,
I'm sure they'd enjoy this stuff too.
I'll put a link down in the info
on the video, please click it.
The least you could do is
check the website out.
If you're an engineer, it's
really really cool stuff.
I got my dad a chicken, for father's day.
And I want to show you a
pretty interesting method
that chickens have to
keep their heads stable.
You know, in guidance and control
you have feedback loops,
and so you have to know your position
and where your relative motion is
going so you can compensate for it,
but chickens are really good at this so...
I'll show you. Watch his
head stay totally stationary
as I move his body...
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.